et puis du théâtre enfin avec cyrano de
bergerac la pièce événement avait été
largement récompensé au dernier molière
et bien tout ce qu'ils avaient raté à la
comédie française pourront se rattraper
dans quelques instants sur france 2
sophie j'ouvre didier dame michelle wie
der most triomphe dans le rôle le plus
célèbre du théâtre français
disons un héros auquel se sont attaqués
tous les plus grands et chaque seibert
francis huster jean piat syncope
c'est un but ce cas c'est une
appellation c'est tonton cyrano où le
panache d'un perdant magnifique village
tenté mais tentative nul ce nouveau menu
matin est un petit
un festin théâtrale servi par la qualité
du jeu
la poésie des décors même christian
lacroix ya mis sa touche en imaginant
des costumes qui mélange des époques
une alchimie qui fait salle comble ce
qui est passionnant dans ce spectacle
c'est que le public passe par tous les
sentiments
on est par moments extrêmement ému à
d'autres moments c'est très drôle
à d'autres moments encore c'est poétique
c'est inouï c'est surréaliste qui est
étonnant c'est que cette pièce qui est
une des plus rentables du répertoire
parle attire les foules est en même
temps un éloge du non rentables de
nouveaux tirs
c'est ce paradoxe cela qui est très
touchant et chaque soir un nouveau né
pour michelle wie der most dans ce rôle
tonitruant est terrible c'est copieux on
va dire que c'est un gros machin
voilà qu'il faut aborder tranquillement
pape doucement on pourrait accumuler les
morceaux de bravoure de cyrano porté par
l'écriture d'edmond rostand qui rentrent
au comédien le plus beau des hommages si
j -r que le samu mien de cyrano de
bergerac qui fut tout et qui ne fut rien